eine ganze reihe von maßnahmen ergriffen
um
das leben ist der
menschen im don was zu erleichtern
um das ist die industrielle güter aus
dem don was auf den russischen markt zu
bringen und es wurde ein erlass
verabschiedet
der die erlangung der russischen
staatsbürgerschaft erleichtert wir haben
ich hoffe dass diese ganzen
beschränkungen die mit der
handelsblockade verbunden waren kiew
ausgerufen hatte in der vergangenheit
legen wir haben heute praktische
aufgaben diskutiert die autos die sich
aus den verträgen über freundschaft
zusammenarbeit und gegenseitigen
beistand ergeben um eine vertrags
rechtliche basis für unsere interaktion
für unsere zusammenwirken zu schaffen
und das pedal für einige dutzend der
verträge halle ministerium behörden und
ihre partner in den slums werden
entsprechende verbindung aufnehmen und
die regeln abstimmen
die
zwischen regierungs- absprachen treffen
wir integrieren werden
ökonomisch militärisch
humanitären also kurzum gesagt in
sämtlichen bereichen
die normale staaten untereinander
pflegen wir hatten noch einmal bestätigt
dass wir die grundlage volkes republiken
unterstützen in ihrem bestreben ihre
unabhängigkeit auszubauen in ihrem
bestreben ihre rechte wahrzunehmen in
erster linie die das recht auf dieser
erde zu leben und das recht auf
kulturelle sprachliche und andere
tradition der bevölkerung des donners
die über die jahrhunderte entstanden
sind und ist wie das ukrainische team
unterwandern wollte wir werden eine
reihe von konsultationen durchführen
zwischen unseren debatten us wir werden
hospitationen für die
mitarbeiter der
außenministerien der donetsk und lanz
gefolgt republiken durchführen und das
sind nützliche praktische ergebnisse
unserer heutigen begegnung
umfragen
kanal
einen schönen guten tag ich hoffe dass
man mich hört ja wir sehen sie sogar
als einen schönen guten tag herr
präsident selensky hatte gesagt dass sie
zu verhandlungen bereit ist
[Musik]
und niemand will verhandeln es moskau
nicht zu irgendwelchen verhandlungen
bereit und wenn ja zu welchen
bedingungen präsident valentin die
unwahrheit gesagt
valencia den
verhandlungen in mindestens zwei
dimensionen erst als er
kategorisch
sich kategorisch geweigert hat dem ins
grab kommen zu erfüllen und die ganze
zeit über an die staatliche umstürze
anzuerkennen oder einem regime
entgegenzukommen das einen völkermord
gegen einen teil seines eigenen volkes
ausgerufen hat es gegen die russische
sprache handelt gegen die russiche
bildung gegen viele dinge die mit der
russischen kultur zu tun haben und
integraler bestandteil der modernen
ukrainischen gesellschaft sind und das
betrifft auch die orthodoxe kirche
sein vorgänger hatte damit angefangen
und so lenski sätzlich zerstörung der
kirche
es gibt genügend möglichkeiten
die präsidentin nicht genutzt hat die
sicherheitsgarantien wir hatten die
daten ja vorgeschlagen im dezember
vergangenen jahres sicherheits nun
darangehen zu diskutieren da wusste das
ist zwar bestens unter einer einzigen
bedingungen die
anforderungen sehr übereinkommen zu
füllen die auf höchster ebene im rahmen
der usa unterzeichnet worden dass
niemand seine sicherheit auf kosten der
sicherheit anderer ausbaut er wollte
diese verpflichtung nicht nachkommen und
seine hintermänner im westen seine
görner im westen und haben dazu auch
nicht bewegt uns alle haben immer wieder
behauptet eilig ist die freiheit der
wahl der allianz um die sicherheit der
ukrainische gewährleisten und darum sagt
er jetzt nicht die wahrheit er löst ganz
einfach wenn er erklärt dass er bereits
ist nur einen neutralen status zu
diskutieren wir haben alle möglichen
varianten
vorgeschlagen und die sicherheit zu
gewährleisten
putin hatte das auf der pressekonferenz
mit wen er hat gesagt eine nato
erweiterung ist nicht akzeptabel wir
wollen aber durch gemeinsame verhandlung
und anstrengung solche möglichkeiten für
die gewährleistung der sicherheit suchen
die
entsprechende bedingungen garantieren
und möglichkeiten gedanken wird für die
ukraine für die europäischen länder und
natürlich auch die russische föderation
unsere initiativen zur gewährleistung
der sicherheit vom dezember vergangenen
jahres
fielen auf die suche von garantie von
garantien auf abriss rahmen der
erweiterung von militärischen stunden
ist insbesondere der nato und des vice
president soll in ski und er soll jetzt
solche sachen einfach nicht erzählen die
nächste frage nbc
welches ist das ziel dieser kooperation
ist
[Musik]
worin besteht das ziel dieser operation
in einem demokratisch gewählten
präsidenten
selensky zu stürzen und gibt es einen
exakten sie haben mir gesagt dass sie
die ukraine nicht besetzen wollen und
wenn russland eine pro russische
regierung installiert haben wird wie
sollen die russischen truppen
sie vertreten ja einvernehmen
und das haben die erklärung von
präsident putin nicht gelesen die er am
gestrigen morgen abgegeben hat das
wundert mich
auf die fragen die sie jetzt gestellt
haben
diese botschaft und taschen und
umstellungen lenkt die aufmerksamkeit
noch mal darauf dort wurde alles klipp
und klar gesagt
wir sehen
keine regierung als demokratisch
anzuerkennen die unterdrückte die
methoden des völkermordes gegenüber dem
eigenen volk
von welchen positionen aus beleuchten
sie die aktuellen aktuellen ereignisse
des coaches viel versteht eine
demokratische gesellschaft
so einsteigen wenn eine sprache verboten
wird sie von einem großteil oder
der überwiegenden mehrheit einer
bevölkerung gesprochen wird
das verbot bildung in russischer sprache
so verdienten
muttersprache im alltäglichen leben zu
verwenden auch wenn man den laden geht
oder im hotel einchecken will oder
sonstwo in der öffentlichkeit ist das
akzeptierten demokratischen gesellschaft
politiker wird es akzeptiert werden
erklärt wird dass menschen
auf dem ein teil des territoriums der
ukraine befinden keine menschen und
menschen
sowie personen
vizepräsident selensky nennt wir haben
heute auch darüber gesprochen
die präsidentin
geworden versprochen hat nach einer
demokratischen wahl sie sich sagen wie
er sich sein falls gegenüber verhalten
wie gesagt bei uns in unserer ukraine
die sie schon polanskis wird es
kindergärten schulen essen vergnügen und
wohlstand geben und die die da zeigte
mit dem finger richtung don was werden
in kellern sitzen und dort verfaulen und
sind etwas ähnliches hat auch präsident
so lenz wie gesagt als er forderte dass
diejenigen die sich der russischen
kultur zugehörig fühlen aus der ukraine
verschwinden sollen stellen sie sich vor
in irland verbietet man plötzlich
wie würde großbritannien darauf
reagieren oder soll man den belgien die
französische sprache verbieten würde ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass eine
solche
gesetzgebung initiative ein paar stunden
oder tage überdauern würden aber im
westen
durch das wissen der eigenen
egoistischen interessen wahrgenommen
wenn man irgendwie beeinträchtigt dann
schreien sie los dann gibt es lärm aber
wenn sprachliche kulturelle
und letztendlich auch religiöse und
rechte von millionen und abermillionen
menschen in der ukraine beeinträchtigt
werden dann
nicht von menschenrechten sondern vom
demokratischen in gänsefüßchen charakter
des regimes darum lesen sie von den
lesen sie seine cent botschaft niemand
hat vor die ukraine zu versetzen das
ziel der operation wochen gelernt die
entmilitarisierung und entnazifizierung
weil
die durch ständigen fackelzügen
etwas hoch lebe hoch loben der nazis das
kultivieren von nazi gewohnheit einen so
genannten freiwilligen bataillonen dass
die schweigende medien
und ich muss noch ein dings hinzufügen
diese journalisten damals irgendwann
das ereignis an der kontakt linie
permanent beleuchtet worden das von
dudley
der landwehren waren immer unsere
journalisten rund um die uhr und sie
haben gesagt wie man den zivilen sechser
vernichtet wie man frauen kennen sagte
wiemann
objektes beschießt immer geschützt sein
müssen ansonsten ist das ein
kriegsverbrechen
sowie die nato luftwaffe belgrad
bombardiert
auf brücken beschossen sagt
unter beschuss genommen
[Musik]
wir sind daran ist dass das ukrainische
volk unabhängig ist dass es eine
regierung hat
nicht
unterstützen und ein völkermord
gegenüber russen durchzuführen ungefähr
so
ja jetzt die bbc bitte rosenberg
danke schön herr minister
lassen wir mal alle käufer müssen
beiseite
das ist keine militärische
spezialoperation das ist eine
vollumfängliche russische oberen der
ukraine wir können sie eine eroberung
einer friedlichen und nation ihre
nachbarn nation rechtfertigen
sie beschießen die ukraine
die ukraine gen osten will nicht gehen
wissen was wir müssen in hand mit trifft
da können wir uns von den angelsachsen
eine ganz fette scheibe abschneiden
die ganzen intervention schauen uns
immer gegen jugoslawien das war der
kampf um demokratie keinerlei
euphemismen alles klar oder schauen sie
die zerstörung des irak die zerstörung
libyens da ging es auch um demokratie
tausende und abertausende zu der das
heißt für max sich trete mit ihnen kein
euphemismus wettbewerb aber was die
antwort ihre antwort auf ihre frage an
betrifft
wo sie hinwollen da hätte man von anfang
an nachdenken sollen
2008 in bukarest auf dem russland nato
gipfel gewarnt
dreimal überlegen sollte in der
nordatlantischen allianz
bevor man irgendwo aufschreit georgien
und ukraine kommen die nato
man sagte das war eine riesen
kompromisse in deutschland und
frankreich erzielt haben wenn weil die
amerikaner wollten ja sofort die
mitgliedschaft der ukraine und
haltet inne
das land ist gerade selbstständig
geworden und baut diese
selbstständigkeit aus und putin hat
schon damals gesagt dass er auch in
seinen aufsätzen geschrieben hat wie
zerbrechlich der ukrainische staat ist
wie sorgsam man mit ihm umgehen muss
aber unsere nato kollegen haben ohne
jedwede euphemismen angefangen mit dem
kulturelle rost ukraine der
pro-westlichen bandera mentalität
unterzuordnen rund 6 gezielt war für
mich schon damals offenkundig
und damit es keine häuser müssen gibt
wir wollen dass das ukrainische volk wie
präsident putin gesagt hat alle häuser
die auf dem gebiet der modernen ukraine
erleben die möglichkeit haben in
freiheit ohne versuche dass man sie in
den so gegriffen bann der
psychologie drei tiere zukunft bestimmen
russland wird die entmilitarisierung und
entnazifizierung
gewährleistet wir haben zu viel gelitten
unter dem nazismus untersuch griechische
volk da kann man die augen nicht
verschließen und leichte nicht sein was
die
demilitarisierung die entmilitarisierung
betrifft
lesen sie doch
amerikanische generale und obristen im
ruhestand erst wenn sie im ruhestand
sind sagen sie die wahrheit und sie
sagen alle
dass die usa
niemals
die stationierung von waffen in ihren
nachbarländern deutschen sollten
obwohl 2000 2008 und den bukarest gipfel
über dollar der vertreter der usa bei
der nato hat diese entscheidungen
bukarest als größten fehler in der
geschichte der allianz bezeichnet ohne
irgendwelche vermissen
[Musik]
chinesische nachrichten
ich entschuldige mich
mein name ist ich bin
gerade in der ukraine deswegen wurde er
von der unmöglichkeit angestellt ist
machen sie zu dass die chinesische
nachrichtenagentur eine frage stellt
denn das ist schon viel zu viel für sie
im moment befinde ich mich in kiew herr
minister und kiew im moment
geschossen es gibt bombenangriffe
bisschen geben sie das wort dem
chinesischen journalisten
warum sind die russischen truppen im
moment in der ukraine
warum wird
warum geben sie das wort den
chinesischen journalisten ich bitte sie
die chinesische nachrichtenagentur stt
ein sie mit ihrer frage
können sie bittet steigen man hat mir
schienen gerade das wort erteilt wenn
sie sich im moment in der ukraine finden
und sie haben keinen anstand haben wir
nichts damit zu tun
ich bitte ihn noch einmal das wort der
chinesischen nachrichtenagentur zu geben
thomas ist etwas vorgefallen läuft etwas
schief
was ist los
routiniert es gibt keinen ton
ich kann vor lesen sie haben uns die
frage geschickt ist ja bitte lesen sie
freut die frage wurde an uns geschickt
ein moment
einen effekt seitens der westlichen
fraktion die moment verabschiedet wurden
was denken sie was werden sie bewirken
was ist ihre meinung darüber kann man
noch das diplomatische regeln nachdem
anfangs der spezialstation wir waren
immer für eine diplomatische lösung
russland hat die führung der rolle dabei
gespielt um eine stufe lässiges
fundament für eine diplomatische
entscheidungen zu legen vor dem münster
vereinbarungen in der bundesrepublik und
in der so hans kopp volksrepublik die
ihre unabhängigkeit verkündet haben
wollten diese entscheidung nicht ändern
die von ihrer bevölkerung getroffen
wurde und ausgerechnet russland hat die
führende rolle dabei gespielt
man hat sie überzeugt die minsker
vereinbarungen zu unterzeichnen gemäss
diesen vereinbarungen wurde die
territoriale integrität und souveränität
der ukraine gesichert unter der
bedingung dass
das keiner einen besonderen status
bekommt in erster linie ist dass die
russischen sprache auch das recht die
eigenen rechtsschutzbehörden zu haben
besonderen wirtschaftlichen beziehungen
zu russland das sind die wichtigsten
punkte
dieser status musste natürlich in der
verfassung verankert werden technischen
verfassung nicht die ambition musste
verkündet werden
alle
handelsblockaden mussten aufgehoben
werden wir unsere schenkung eingeführt
wurden und natürlich mussten die wahlen
stattfinden
nach der abstimmung mit diesen
demzufolge all diese sieben jahre nach
der unterzeichnung der minsker
vereinbarungen haben wir mehrfach
versucht
uns auch die westlichen schutzpatron zu
überzeugen in berlin beides branchen die
war richtig dazu zu bringen dass dieses
schlüssels punkte erfüllen denn davon
ging es ab dass die ukrainische
integriert wiederhergestellt werden wenn
sie die elementaren kulturellen und
sprachlichen rechte der bevölkerung von
don budge anerkennen würden niemand hat
einen finger gerührt
damit diese sabotage die sowohl schenk
als auch von see lenski danach
verhinderten
aufrufe die mehrmals stattgefunden sind
auch unsere öffentlichen aufrufe appelle
an das gewissen unserer westlichen
partner das alles wurde nicht gehört
bedauerlicherweise
ich kann es nicht glauben dass die
westlichen politiker und diplomaten
ständig ist ein ganz kategorisch
jegliche versuche ablehnen kiew dazu zu
bringen die minister die vereinbarungen
zur schön und man hat gehofft das wird
ewig so seien sie dachten wir werden uns
ewig anschauen wie die russen
benachteiligt werden die russische
sprache verboten wird eine frage hat sie
natürlich die frage an unsere westlichen
gesprächspartner was ist ein englisch
verboten wird wir würden sie darauf
reagieren
wir hatten jetzt genug bemühungen in dem
konflikt diplomatisch zu regeln und
schüren und die bewaffneten operationen
die jetzt darauf gerichtet sind die
demokratische ordnung wiederherzustellen
ohne neonazismus ohne militarisierung
das alles wird natürlich
wieder besprochen und ich möchte noch
einmal betonen dass es präsident putin
dass wir dafür sind dass die ukraine
entwickelt sie jetzt wäre es dass die
ukraine entnazifiziert wird wir rufen
alle dazu auf dass alle in diesem land
ihre zukunft selbst bestimmt ohne
einfluss von außen die letzte frage
herzlichen dank
wie viele möglichkeiten
hat china
verhandlungen
einige denken man muss diese
verhandlungen und durchführen also wenn
diese verhandlungen stattfinden dann mit
wem ist das usa ist das nahtlos
verhandlungen waren bis zum letzten
moment mit
herrn putin habe ich gesprochen sich
reaktionen seitens unserer kollegen in
der nato sei insbesondere in den usa sie
haben uns für gerechter sicherheits
gerechnet ausgesprochen sie müssten
ehrlich eingehalten werden auf der
grundlage der entscheidungen die bei der
osze auf der höchsten ebene getroffen
wurden man müsste das ehrlich tun ohne
das so zu interpretieren sie der westen
das kollektive interpretiert hat
man hat gesagt allianzen darf man frei
aussuchen aber die sicherheit auf kosten
anderer das wurde alles verschwiegen und
präzis günter brück ist und man sagt das
war alles russisch interpretation wir
akzeptieren das nicht das ist alles eine
lüge
alles was unser lage unser griff die auf
der höchsten politischen ebene
verabschiedet werden stoßen und der
westen wollte nur das sagen was für
käfer regime von vorteil war
vergessen sie den sonderstatus vergessen
sind die wahlen vergessen sie die
ambition und so weiter und sofort
verhandlungen gab es in ausreichendem
maße wenn aber verhandlungen
sabotiert werden wenn das alles ganz
offen geschieht wenn auch noch russland
beschuldigt wird dass russland minsker
vereinbarungen erfüllen sollte das ist
einfach unverschämt wie sie
ich glaube das ist auch ein etwas ein
gasbezug der generell unseren westlichen
partnerin das ist aber nicht mehr
zulässig
ständig gab es dann noch eine
verschlechterung der lage der
russischsprachigen bevölkerung in der
ukraine ich habe es bereits beispiele
angeführt was man mit der russischen
bildung mit der russischen orthodoxen
kirche mit der russische gemacht hat
versuchen sie sich das vorzustellen in
bezug auf ihre tradition stellen sie
sich das einfach vor das geschieht mit
ihnen in ihrem kulturellen raum dann
würden sie verstehen dass man das
einfach nicht aushalten kann also das
ist jetzt kurz gefasst die erklären
wir sind bereit zu verhandlungen sobald
die streitkräfte der ukraine auf den
aufruf unseres präsidenten regierung
sobald sie die waffen stilllegen niemand
hat vor sie anzugreifen jemand hat vor
zu benachteiligen sie sollen zu ihren
familien zurückkehren und die
ukrainische bevölkerung soll von uns
allen die gelegenheit bekommen ihr
schicksal zu bestimmen
noch eine frage von ca
guten tag
herzlichen dank dass sie zugestimmt
haben eine frage zu beantworten
ich befinde mich im moment in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt
ich sehe bombenangriffe am rande der
stadt
wir sehen das ist schon die letzten
stunden
eine ganz einfache frage an sie herr
minister
wollen sie
die
iranische regierung durch pro russische
regierung ersetzen vielleicht haben sie
bereits dieser frage beantwortet die
durch und verzeihung aber ich würde
gerne die antwort auf diese frage
planen sie die ukrainische regierung zu
entfernen und eine neue regierung zu
installieren
ich habe direkt gehören doch das erste
mal als ich gefragt habe ich erkläre
ihnen noch einmal sie wollen gar nicht
zu hören ich habe bereits auf die fragen
von anderen westlichen medien
geantwortet und ich habe bereits gesagt
wird dass putin eine antwort gegeben
habe ich weiß sie wollen jetzt nicht
diese erklärung und lesen da wird ganz
ausführlich erklärt wie die russische
position ist und ich lade sie ganz
herzlich dazu ein dass sie das lesen
vielleicht beraten sie sich auch mit den
anderen kollegen empfehlen sie das ihrem
ukrainischen kollegen auf den spanischen
schreibkräften niemand
das ukrainische volk anzugreifen wie
schön dass du uns niemand hat
uns jedes sagen dass die neonazis und
alle die für genutzt und in diesem lande
herbst
das regime was ich im moment befindet
wird von zwei mechanismen von außen
beeinflusst es gibt einerseits westens
mit usa als oberhaupt und andererseits
gibt es nicht sie versuchen
nur verbreiten sonst in dieser kultur
die sie befinden sich im moment in kiew
was ihre gefühle betrifft sage ich noch
einmal lesen sie bitte was sie haben
keine angriffe regelung gibt das auf
zivile
die keine angriffe auf die ukrainischen
streitkräfte im bunten scheiben um den
anderen orten
außerhalb von militärobjekten es gibt
keine militärangriffe dieser art diese
statistik die uns vorliegt bestätigt das
meiner meinung nach
als vertreter eines unabhängigen sender
würde ich in eine frage stellen ich habe
bereits gesagt dass ich die vor der
frage beantwortet habe dieses thema habe
ich bereits gustavos warum
war es der fall dass innerhalb von
diesen letzten acht jahren niemand von
den westlichen journalisten
erzählt hat was
im westen geschickt westlich der kontakt
linien
sie sind jetzt erschrocken was in kiew
passiert aber gab es mal jemanden von
nennen don was selbst haben sie gesehen
wie die schulen zerstört werden haben
sie gesehen wie frauen zerstört werden
die babys in ihren armen haben
haben sie gesehen wie strände
bombardiert werden voller kinder war
jemand schon mal da
ich bin der meinung dass sich ihre
fragen stellen sollen basierend auf
tatsachen und tatsachen sind in der
erklärung von herrn putin beschrieben
herzlichen dankeschön diskutiere
teilnahme ist somit ist die
pressekonferenz bedanken
dann und herren eine bemerkenswerte
pressekonferenz markus kaim von der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik hat
auch mir zugehört er kann also erstens
dass außenminister fragen an westliche
pressevertreter wert an der
pressekonferenz stellt ist ja schon mal
ungewöhnlich aber das ganze ist doch ein
seltsames schauspiel erstens die
begriffe die benutzt werden die
anschuldigungen und beschuldigungen die
da genannt werden was was was was lesen
sieht doch aus wie wird man fast ratlos
oder
also was wir gehört haben ist letztlich
die selbe generativ wie wir es aus den
letzten tagen oder wochen gehört habe es
handelt sich nicht um einen
zwischenstaatlichen konflikt zwischen
der ukraine und brust gas sondern
russland ist zu einer befreiung sagt die
uns einer schutz aktion aufgebrochen um
die gedichte geknechtete tradierte
russische minderheit in dollars oder den
anteil der ukraine frei das ist die
leser so russischen sei nicht komplett
anders als die ukrainische regierung
komplett anders als die westlichen
regierung aber sie setzt sich fort so
setzte ich dass fotos prozent der woche
gemacht noch weise verfolgen kann und
interessant kann ich mir zwei dinge
erstens er keine antwort auf die frage
geben ob die russische regierung darauf
ab die ukrainische regierung zu stürzen
als gesagt das richte sich nicht gegen
die streitkräfte spricht sich einige
völker so lässt jetzt schluss naheliegt
es geht auch darum die regierung zu
stürzen und das zweite das interessant
vielfachen verweise auf fehlverhalten
des westens und die referenzpunkte sind
da deutlich kosovo libyen und
die usa wien kriege also den westen
interveniert hat unter verweis auf
menschenrecht auf unterdrückung
kino zieht das hat russland nicht
vergessen das ist tief eingegraben und
das sollte jetzt rausgeholt und gegen
west problem ja das macht er ja also
kategorisch das ist ja diese verbot der
russischen sprache da gab es ja das muss
man einfach auch sagen die ukraine hat
sich auch nicht immer sehr korrekt
verhalten da waren auch manchmal dinge
dabei wo man sagt ja wenn sie jetzt
zitiert werden das muss man sich
gefallen lassen aber dass sie immer noch
zitiert werden wie da hat man ja daran
gearbeitet dass die russische sprache da
quasi aus dem land verbannt wird solche
dinge oder auch die nicht gerade das
große engagement
die minsk das minsker abkommen
tatsächlich umzusetzen von seiten auch
der kirche regierung das sind natürlich
dinge da kann man sagen ja ihr habt da
jetzt nicht vollkommen unrecht aber
daraus abzuleiten nazis und eine
entnazifizierung davon
abzuleiten als handlungsauftrag und eine
demilitarisierung das ist doch schon das
ist ja schon perfide oder in der tat der
ambivalenz in der russischen
argumentation marke so schwierig dass
ein so glücklich zu erfassen oder
einfach möglich zu fassen in der rede
vom montagabend ist es ja noch massen an
zweigeteilte signal das erste signal
bezog sich auf den donnerstag große
sprachen das hätte letztlich nahegelegt
ein begrenztes militärisches eingängigen
die verwaltungsgebiet und jetzt ganz
also vielleicht etwas überwiegen
battiston gebieten hinaus das hätte aber
so sagen eine begrenzte
militäroperationen
der zweite verweise differenzieren zu
recht um die begrifflichkeiten
entnazifizierung und die militarisierung
der ukraine konkret der regierung der
regierungsbehörden das öffnete doch die
tür für ein weiteres feld nicht genau
für die von kommentieren
das heißt ganz korrekt ist ein ganz
ernst nimmt sich die
große politik nicht wahr das problem
hätte sich durch eine schutzzone
anders regeln können und so haben ja
auch westliche vertreter im kosovo ist
um eine schutzzone das ging nicht und
dem sturz des regimes im
vergleich auch nicht ganz passen sondern
tatsächlich so problematisch denn
völkerrechtliche hinsicht im mini tieres
intervention der nato im kosovo gegeben
ist das völlig unstrittig gefragt ist
doch gerne
ich sage an dieser stelle mal danke
schön wir können wahrscheinlich noch
sehr viel reden über die dinge die da
passieren da sind wir schon erste mal
für den moment markus kaim
dann ist es doch irgendwie kaum zu
fassen alles meine damen und herren wir
sind aus der pk aus der pressekonferenz
des robert-koch-instituts chefs und des
bundesgesundheitsministers leider
rausgegangen weil wir gesagt haben wir
müssen gucken wie sich dort sergey
lavrov der russische außenminister aus
lässt in seiner pressekonferenz sie
können aber rk ii und
bundesgesundheitsminister nachschauen
wenn sie wollen bei phoenix de im
internet und bei facebook bekommen sie
die pressekonferenz
zum nachschauen zum anschauen geliefert
von uns und wir gehen jetzt apropos
pressekonferenz wieder in die
bundespressekonferenz denn da läuft
jetzt schon die regierungs
pressekonferenz an
ich muss eines vorausschicken aufgrund
der aktuellen lage die uns hier
sicherlich ja auch gleich noch
intensiver beschäftigen wird gibt es
natürlich eine gewisse vorbehalte was
die verlässlichkeit angeht das ist die
planung wie sie und sich heute darstellt
aber die lage ist dynamisch und wenn
sich etwas ändert teilen wir das mit für
den kommenden sonntag dem 27 februar
tritt der deutsche bundestag wie sie
wissen zu einer